moi je crois à cette force cette force
de devoir garantir aux générations
futures le droit à un environnement sain
et c'est la les dernières décisions les
derniers propos rapportés par le Conseil
constitutionnel ce qui est certain c'est
quand on s'engage on s'engage pour nous
pour nos enfants et pour la
planète depuis de 2017 nous avons eu
comme objectif de préserver le vivant et
de tenir les accords de Paris une
trajectoire ambitieuse baisser les gaz à
effet de serre objectif - 55 %. protéger
notre territoire hexagonal et ultramarin
plus de 30 % de notre territoire est un
espace protégé mais il faut aller un
petit peu plus loin et c'est l'objectif
qui est le notre aujourd'hui les
engagements ils sont très concrets ils
sont pour notre biodiversité ils sont
pour le climat ils sont pour la
planète
j'ai pu présenter la stratégie nationale
biodiversité à matigon au côté de la
première ministre et du ministre
Christophe Béchu quatre grands axes il y
a 40 grandes familles d'action et puis
200 mesures très concrètes ce n'est pas
un plaédoyer c'est un plan d'action
opérationnelle d'ici 2030 d'abord on
arrête l'effondrement du vivant et en
même temps on restaure la nature pour ça
et bien on préserve des espaces je pense
aux zéro artificiation des sols en terme
de restauration je pense évidemment un
milliard d'arbres évidemment imp planter
d'ici euh 2030 recrutement d'hommes et
de femmes parce que oui nous sommes un
parti humaniste c'est les hommes et les
femmes qui font des qui porent les
politiques publiques recrutement de 140
nouveaux agents 1,2 milliards de moyens
financiers c'est historique pour mettre
en place cette stratégie biodiversité
plus le plan
haut moi je crois que le combat pour le
climat et le combat pour la biodiversité
c'est deux combats jumeaux et qu'il faut
les mener ensemble pour ça il faut
s'appuyer sur tous les moyens qu'on a
aujourd'hui et pour ça je va vous donne
un exemple très concret on réunit tout
le monde et on base nos décisions sur la
science ça veut dire quoi concrètement
on lance par exemple pour la première
fois au monde un inventaire de la
biodiversité un inventaire qui va
s'appuyer sur les nouvelles technologies
donc l'ADN mais aussi sur les méthodes
naturalistes des associations plus
traditionnelles et qui nous permettent
en réalité d'alimenter ses ses
inventaires quand dit biodiversité moi
je pense au vivant alors je sais que ça
peut paraître étonnant mais quand on dit
biodiversité c'est d'abord la nature et
je pense à la nature au plus près de de
de chez moi donc moi je pense à la
Loire